on this episode we talk about competing
with Elon Musk who moves subscriptions
22 year old Gary
[Music]
this is
Gary B
hello everybody and welcome to the ask
Gary the show I am gay Jesus Christ I
really haven't done this in a long time
yeah I mean listen even the best of us
get rusty everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 152 of
the askgaryvee show without me mixing
while every TVs I'm intro Jesus Christ
hey feeling good fired up for the show
clearly and really excited having talked
to you guys in a little bit of time and
I apologize been traveling hustling
making things happen the Jets won I'm
now 5 for 5 on my prediction do you bet
like it's time that people start really
betting I think the Patriots
prediction this Friday's show is going
to be real what's today Wednesday good
we're doing show tomorrow and Friday all
right we're gonna roll India I think
it's time to get into the show
love it let's do it Mario ask suppose
Elon Musk's just started his own media
wine resale company competing with you
in your neighborhood how do you respond
I would risk I would actually be like I
would be fired up happy because that is
my game not Ilan's and so I this is
straight up truth it is insane how when
I hear that question how obvious this is
to me that I would absolutely destroy
him and he would fail miserably if he
was trying to beat me in that game in
the same way that I would fail if I
decided to you know invent rocket ships
into space and and Tesla cars and things
of that nature when I play my game
whatever that is building an agency
building a wine retailer whenever I do
next if I'm operating right forget about
it investing where it's a little bit of
a crapshoot forget about jayvees where I
have partners me me Gary if I'm
operating there's not a single person in
the world that I'm scared of at all ever
because the
only thing that can happen is both of us
getting ours there is nobody that's
gonna beat me
the markets are too big I'm gonna get
mines and so I'm not scared
Elan or Shmuel on or sucks or cubes or
Ashton or anybody about anything that
comes to do with the game that I'm
playing cuz I'm gonna win I'm gonna win
could they possibly do more business me
sure I mean I'm not excited about that
but sure I guess it could happen I don't
think there's another agency over the
last four years that has grown at the
size that we have but and in the liquor
business the same thing happened but of
course somebody can come along with that
kind of talent but that's not gonna stop
me from getting mine and so the answer
to your question is I would be pumped
because I think there would be a lot of
people talking about why did Ilan lose
his mind and go and do small businesses
and - I would enjoy the victory that I
would get which would get me more street
cred for punching you on in the mouth
James ass why not go halves on the Jets
or quarters and elevate the team to the
level only Gary could the owner has to
see some value in your methods seems
like this might be something more
realistic and attained sooner is it all
or nothing
James it's all or nothing mainly because
the owners not interested I mean Woody
Johnson is a billionaire he's doing his
thing he's not a he's not outwardly
reaching out to me he's rolling and
going about his merry way
and and that's that and he's in control
of that situation I'm not worried about
it I'm focusing on what I can control
which is amass enough wealth and and
power an opportunity and narrative and
leverage and branding to give me the
best shot to actually pull this off and
so that's why I plus I would never go in
for an ask right I would never be like
hello mr. Johnson why don't you sell me
25% of the company or things that nation
just not in me I'm gonna take it if I
deserve it
I'll get it if I'm good enough and and
so I'm focusing every piece of my energy
doing things to put me in that position
because the amount of luck and
serendipity that has to happen for me to
even get that at-bat literally the
passing of the company on whatever would
he decide to do with it hopefully
hopefully he hones it his whole life and
hopefully lives for a very long time and
hopefully because I'm much younger
they're in a position to make that
purchase if his family doesn't want to
hold on to it so there's just a million
different variables that come into play
that um that have to fall into place but
I just need to focus on what I can
control and really for everybody that's
the biggest thing way too many of you
and I've been really digging into my
community in the last three or four days
a lot of this is actually turned into a
really good question
a lot of uh a lot of you were just
worrying about [ __ ] you can't control
like it's unbelievable I I don't know
what's the matter with you like you
can't control it the end like it's not
super complicated you can't control the
weather you can't like people literally
crying that it rained during their like
flea market or Food Fair or I don't
remember exactly was like okay but like
like and then like then I was like okay
maybe was just a single ramp but like
seven tweets I'm like well like like
we're rained like Mother Nature [ __ ] you
take it like a woman and like you know
and so you know I just uh I just don't
believe in crying over things you cannot
control and so I I just think about the
things I can control and so it please
try to take this answer and understand
how important it is to not dwell but
instead reverse it and think about what
you can be doing during that time you
know if it rains it when it rained
during times I've done flea markets I
packed up and went dollar store in Toys
R Us shopping you know they I didn't
just sit there and take my rain yeah
Yanik asks what's your opinion on always
wanting more in life good bad why that's
a really good question my my point of
view on this is both always wanting more
in life seriously while being very very
content and happy at the same time
that's what I am you know this is
something you may not know though I
would be disappointed and my ego boy my
ego which is a nice part of me would
really take a hit if a little weird
genie showed up right now
weird genie got it boom if the weird
genie said to me hey Gary I'm the weird
jeanny of the future bad news you're not
gonna grow anymore this is it you've
plateaued I'd be like oh like a big shot
but I'd like all right like to me like
I've I've had a great run already like
I've done really well and and many
people would be really happy to have
these professional accolades and
successes as their entire life's work
that would rip my heart out of my body
right now if that would to be true you
don't have the enemy then ripping my
heart out Mortal Kombat [ __ ] here but it
is probably surprising to some of you
because I don't talk about it as much
how content I actually am and so my
point of view on it is a very strong
balance of happiness and content with
what you've got while being very hungry
and striving for real real victories and
upside than the climb and the game and
so that's where I'm at and then as you
can imagine as you're probably listening
to this that makes me very happy like
it's probably a big reason I'm so damn
happy it's a nice place to be you're
like that X idiot I'm ripping it with
you today
yeah really winning Wendy over thank you
it's Robin Norgren with faith and
creativity calm and Josie's art-school
thanking you for all that you share with
us entrepreneurs or would-be
entrepreneurs so my question is that
Hulu made a decision recently to offer
its subscribers the option to have ad
free subscriptions and wanted to know
what your thoughts are on that
we will keep asking questions I'm so
glad that you keep answering them
thanks Gary Vee you got it thank you for
such a darling video loved your earrings
by the way I think it's a smart business
model some people value time he adds
enough to pay for a subscription other
people are willing to go the other route
they don't want to pay for the
subscription I think giving customers
two or three options my preference is
three I think there's a lot of
interesting psycho data around that
to how they want to experience a
platform is very very smart I think it
lends itself to high higher profit
margins especially when you do three and
and so I think that's a very smart move
by Hulu I do not believe that one one
especially for a platform one option is
the way to go as a matter of fact if I
ever do a book by myself self publish
because now I'm a free agent after this
Lex book comes out
that's right HarperCollins call me back
i I I would probably do some really
interesting three different pricing
models where you get different options I
think there's a interesting dynamics
around that so I think Hulu made a very
smart decision as a matter of fact I
haven't done a question of the day but
I'm gonna throw one in for the role just
a little side question would love to see
how many people would rather have one
minute well how many ads are there in a
Hulu probably like 3 2 or 3 minutes
right how many people are more into like
you'll deal with the three minutes or
how many people would rather pay like
the 8 bucks or whatever it is a month 13
got it so curious yep YouTube red saw
that haven't dug in yet but yeah I mean
look I think subscription models are
very smart I think people are willing to
pay for it if they get the value of the
content I think a lot of people would
pay for this show if I ever decided to
to convert it not a whole lot but
something other matter that's another
side question if you were to pay and put
$0 in the comments on Facebook and
YouTube if you were to pay what would
you pay for a month subscription of the
askgaryvee show be really good data and
be really important for me and I'm not
gonna do it so don't worry I just want
another truth so don't try to make me
feel good
and I'm trying to razz me just tell me
the truth that I was like this was it
the next 150 the rest of my life I'm
going to a subscription per month here
you know minimum of five twenty minimum
of what do you think guaranteed eleven
episodes per month twelve I feel like
that we're at least minimally ringing on
that as many as twenty what would you
pay that'd be interesting too I think
it's good learnings for all of us so
keep it real
Danis with 22 year-old Gary Vee have
watched the askgaryvee show with 22
year-old Gary B has two askgaryvee show
that's a question the answer is no which
is interesting but true twenty-two year
old Gary knew he had it and didn't want
to learn from other things which I don't
know if it's a strength or a weakness
but he he believed in what he had in his
body and I believed in what I was gonna
be and felt that my fresh naive eyes and
my intuition was more valuable than
putting things in my head which would
then be known as well look at how that
person did it and they did it well I
truly do believe that one of the reasons
so many of you watch this show is
because I say things different I come
from different angles and I really do
believe that's because I don't consume
anybody else's stuff I think it helps me
keep fresh I think I think my stuff
comes from operating I think you know
just don't give me a wide view because
the background changed I think my stuff
comes from actually operating I think my
stuff comes from an intuitive place and
I I don't I don't try to consume
anything as in fact I was at this event
where there was an opening keynote
during the dinner where I had a like
meet with a client boy and I really
didn't like it it was a really bad
experience when I want to like go up I
literally wanted to go on stage and hit
him with a chair WPF style and take over
my god and that you know like like and
and and just don't feel like that's my
learning style like I'm so 22 year old
Gary would spit in the face of the
askgaryvee show
sorry Dirac and and that's that missed
you guys a lot really pumped to be back
in the saddle we'll try to bring it
stronger and harder tomorrow you keep
asking questions I'll keep answering
them
[Music]